so next round
here I hope this time with a slightly better
outcome yes but a short
wait
Game
started Karl matell from Norway
22 well knight
C6 yes well then we'll just go into some
chigorin stuff like that no he plays
D6 well let's just do normal
development  That ca
n't
be wrong,
of course I don't have the slightest idea
about it, well that's how you find yourself in a
kind of strange E4 kind of position,
well I'll
admit
that the bishop really has no place on B5
if the pawn is now on
C4 instead of C2 hour  I would
feel comfortable yes he would like to draw runner G5
so runner F3 runner F3 runner
G5 well we can take that out again
A6
mysterious maybe he wants A4 B5 but it's
definitely a strange
idea well I'll get the
runner first  okay he can also move bishop H5
but
yes but he
still does it of course it looks kind of
strange normally the bishop is
pretty worthless in such a position
yes come on I gain space
here like this on H5 then rook G1 with a
decent
space advantage can of course knight C5
move and maybe take my bishop D3.
Well, I would like to play knight E2 G3
so that C4 might be possible,
otherwise he could still
play C6, which also
looks plausible on H5, just rook
G1 yes, so the bishop on G6 is
usually here now
night watchman knight F6 yes
I had just
seen that one too, still on E4,
so at least I can't
do the regrouping just described
with Knight
E2. I still have concerns about
opening it somehow with C6. I'll
try A4, yes, C6, yes
force to get pawns to D5
okay then I have to send him
away wasn't exactly on the
plan
but so knight
H5 knight H4 F5 is that an idea he
can move knight F4 but
I could take that knight G6 H4 F4 away yes I
have to do something  active
play here, well, in any case, he
managed to create a position that
you have never seen before,
yes, consistently, okay, Bishop F4 EF
Knight G6 HG H4 then he can take G5,
I haven't seen or
taken it, yes, that's a shame because he has
of course the whole story is
set up yes that's very unpleasant for
white
yes well I can't leave him there
so okay what other options do you have
he's about to play bishop
G5 knight
F5
h yes the bishop will come to F6 I have to
play faster come on
E5 are trying to be more active here,
I only have a minute
10 so all in all it looks pretty
terrible
so
okay yes Run 5 okay yes I wanted to
move it anyway The
idea is now h4 h5 maybe you can get
a nice square for the knight on E4
yes  time
warning yes D5 hangs
but I can then take G6 and
D5 well
at least you have an active
knight after knight C6 is
of course
still just
fine so maybe so D3 E4
so very very
easy way for your king
fortunately there is
no way and I  catch up a bit in time,
well it's still very critical
B5 he can't
play
H5 doesn't actually bring
me C3 squares
away B5 I just have knight bad
F6 tower D8 but would be a good
move with
certainly tower
C8 okay come on
tower H5 now  makes rook H5 GH Queen
H7 just go
G5 okay
H6 I have F6 under fire at the moment
so now I can
schagenck check
takes
and d 7 bishop
G7 knight Schl G5 well well Queen F5 threatens
at least Queen
F5
check wow in the next checkmate with 4
Seconds that was luck, yes I was
of course more than modest, yes
strange opening he played there
but at least I didn't
rebut it